hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round three of this
year's Tata still chess tournament it is
param makulu versus nbe abdat param
coming off from that very very tough
loss to Ala fuja and nck well he had two
fairly calm draws in rounds one and two
uh it's a pretty pretty crazy game you
guys will love it uh let's check it out
so param with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to C4 he goes for the English
opening Pawn to E5 we have Knight to C3
Knight to F6 and now Knight to F3 of
course the three Knights of the English
we have Pawn to E4 and now Knight to G5
and here uh there are a couple of very
interesting ways to go about this
position as the E4 Pawn is hanging but
Notre Beck goes Pawn to C6 he said that
uh okay uh param had a pretty tough game
yesterday and he might be still shook
from his loss to Ala so let's play a a
crazy game where I'm going to sacrifice
a pawn and uh anything could happen and
param declines this uh the way you
usually play this is you take the pawn
then black again goes after the Knight
with D5 let's see capture here Knight
back to G3 and now you have to decide
whether you just want to continue
developing or you want to continue
chasing the Knight and if something like
E3 you can further Chas CH chase the
Knight and if Knight to C6 let's say D4
and queen F6 uh you get something like
this where black has a very active
position black still has the bishop pair
uh Queen already inter in the game the
possibility of H3 The Rook can come into
the game it's uh very very enjoyable but
for the price of one Pawn however param
does not want that and he plays Queen to
A4 now it's very interesting as Queen to
A4 is is an incredibly rare move uh one
of the players who has played it with
the white pieces though is nbec abdat
himself so maybe playing some Mind Games
here uh and okay we have Queen to E7 and
now uh in the game that we mentioned it
was played in the uh in the Lindor Sai
was the Memorial Tournament of 2021
Abdus satov played this against David
paravian and he went back with Queen to
C2 but here uh sorry um yeah with Queen
to C2 but here we have Pawn to F3 uh and
this is where param deviates from the
line that Notre Beck played and it is
now as of move six that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens e captures Knight captures and
now Pawn to G6 just trying to uh F care
to the bishop and Castle the king to
save
uh Pawn to D4 we have Bishop to G7 and
now even Pawn to C5 looks like a looks
like an odd move but uh you're really
going after that D6 Square you're
preventing Pawn to D5 or Pawn to D6 and
you want to play Bishop to F4 and Bishop
to D6 while Black's Queen side is still
uh undeveloped and well you could go for
something like B6 try and break up the
pawn chain right away uh another B just
castles and now Bishop to F4 going after
that pawn to D6 move but just goes
Knight to A6 uh he mentioned in an
interview after the game that he uh saw
this exchange sacrifice somewhere so
it's not novelty for him over the board
uh I don't know if uh maybe he was
talking about the exact same position or
maybe just the idea of the exchange
sacrifice here but that he is aware that
it's possible and he goes for Knight to
A6 now offering Bishop to D6 which param
goes for attacks the queen queen to E3 H
but he doesn't take the Rook he first
kicks away the queen Knight back to D1
now the queen has to go back Queen to E6
and now comes a very interesting move
not Bishop captures on f8 but Knight to
F2 and notbe said in an interview after
the game that he was very much surprised
by this move not going for material but
that also uh he could understand it as
uh White has an immense positional grip
here with the bishop on D6 uh but uh if
you guys want to see what happens if
Bishop captures an f8 well Anything
Could Happen obviously but if Bishop
captures an f8 and something like E3 uh
then B5 comes you kick away the queen
and after the queen goes back now you
play Pawn to D6 you start breaking the
the White Center here and with the white
King still on E1 it could be a little
bit dangerous for example C captures
Bishop capture even better Knight to B4
you go after the queen first queen D2
now you capture you defend the Knight
and after something like Bishop to D3
otherwise you cannot develop your Bishop
let's say captures captures and uh okay
now now you're going to be able to
Castle but um it's still a very very
interesting and active position with
black still having the bishop pair once
the bishop could come to F to B7 and
then grab hold of this diagonal also you
can move the queen bring the bishop to
F5 so I mean uh it doesn't look like
grabbing The Rook here is the way to go
so that's why param goes Knight to F2 uh
we have Rook to E8 okay another says you
don't want the material I'm just going
to move it and now Pawn to H4 not not
preparing Pawn to H5 really uh but
securing that G5 Square for the Knight
we have Pawn to B6 finally going after
the pawn chain and Knight to G5 now
going after not Beck's Queen here and
here we have Queen to F5 Queen to D5
would have been more precise uh but this
is um pretty crazy game now comes Pawn
to G4 param tries to sacrifice a pawn
for the attack and the idea is that if
you if you take here for example
captures captures and captures then
Queen B3 puts pressure on the F7 pawn
and now you either play rookie six and
and give up The Rook or you try to
defend with your queen let's say queen
to F5 but then Bishop G2 Rook to F1 and
black will uh suffer uh to say the least
so after G4 we have Queen back to D5 the
the square where the queen originally
was supposed to go and now queenside
castles uh we have B captures and C5 D
captures and C5 opening up an attack
towards nre's Queen uh and now Knight
captures on C5 retaliating by attacking
white the White Queen on A4 and there is
a move that is possible here for white
and it's such an impressive move that it
wins the game on the spot but
interestingly both param and nck missed
it over the board however you guys will
not as you know is it exists feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
a move that these two super Grand
Masters could not and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to I'm kidding it is Queen to A3
uh this is the move that you had to find
and now uh the point is that the Knight
here is hanging you are defending the A2
pawn and also the black queen is still
hanging so there's no good way to handle
this queen to C4 check yes you can move
the queen with check probably why both
of them missed it but after King to B1
uh What uh what now what do you play now
the the there's no good continuation the
the Knight is still hanging you cannot
defend the Knight and if you move the
Knight let's say Knight E4 now comes the
move that probably they both missed uh
Pawn to E3 uh traps the queen there's no
square for the white for the black queen
and doesn't matter if the Knight goes
here you could also go KN back to B7 E4
traps the queen so that's all there is
to it but they missed it Queen A3
obviously probably because the
possibility of the queen moving from the
attack with check made them both uh you
know just okay it's probably nothing so
Queen to C2 was played but now all of a
sudden it is Notre Beck who is in a much
much better position and he goes for
Queen captures on A2 so it will cost him
a knight on C5 uh but uh doesn't matter
so Bishop captures on C5 was played now
Rook to B8 bringing the Rook into the
attack the queen is already here once
the Knight moves also the bishop joins
the attack The Rook on E8 will stop the
king from ever reaching the king side uh
this is not looking good for uh for for
Aram so Pawn to B4 it is as usual the
strongest move trying to trade Queens
but of course just Queen to A3 with
check and now if you go to B1 then the
knight move that we discussed is just
overwhelming and there's no defense here
if Queen A2 even Knight to C3 with a
beautiful uh triple Royal Fork here uh
game over so King to D2 was played he's
trying to escape with his King but now
again Knight to D5 Rook to H3 guarding
the third rank but also with tempo as
the queen is hanging and now comes um uh
now comes Rook to E3 and this is a
beautiful move cutting off The Rook from
attacking the queen and there's just no
good way at to um stop this for example
if Bishop captures on E3 then Queen
captures on B4 with check and once the
B4 Pawn is eliminated it's game over you
will play a few more moves but then
comes Bishop to B2 with check King to B1
Bishop C3 check King to C1 and now okay
you've stopped the king from escaping
here now it's time to check with the
queen queen to beat you only move and
queen captures will be Checkmate and
also it doesn't help you if you if you
take with the Rook yes you do gain
control you still control the third rank
but now just Knight captures on E3 and
The Rook is gone again there is the uh
problem of your king getting checkmated
and now after Bishop captures an E3
because uh how are you going to
recapture uh that's kind of the point of
the line you can't recapture if you
recapture you once again lose sight of
B4 and then it's the exact same line
King to C1 Bishop to B2 with check King
B1 Bishop C3 check
uh and the the the line that we've
already shown so after Rook to E3 param
plays the only move that keeps him in
the game and that is Knight F to
E4 uh probably better was even Knight G
to E4 uh but okay this can also be
played Rook captures on H3 and now how
do you take the rook and should you even
capture The Rook well the problem is if
you take with the Knight let's say you
play Knight captures on H3 then comes
Knight captures on B4 and okay the queen
is attacked
if what can you play here uh not much
whatever you play you're just going to
uh lose and where where do you move the
queen that is also the question not a
lot of squares here you could try some
tricky ideas like Rook to B1 with some
maybe Rook capture on B8 captur on C8
but just Queen A5 you don't have to rush
anything here now you're just
threatening to move the Knight with
Tempo and you black will have to trade
Rook Capt Bishop captures Rook captures
Rook captures Queen captures let's say
King to D1 and now Bishop A6 okay white
is up a piece but the white king stuck
in the center and the bishop pair I mean
that there's no uh there's no way you
can stop this even a nice Bishop C4
Bishop B3 uh it's a game over so after
Rook captures on H3 Bishop captures on
H3 was played it is the correct way to
go and now Pawn to H6 kicking away the
Knight and now Knight back to F3 here
param was already uh very much down on
the clock he was playing on 30 seconds
um uh increment basically uh the move
you have to play is Knight captures an
F7 it's still it's arguable if you if
you have a chance at surviving uh Queen
captures on H3 and now you will bring
the Knight to D6 but still after Bishop
to A6 it's I mean it's uh white king in
the center of the board and all of the
black pieces are coming for that white
king so you would have a chance but not
not a very good one so instead Knight to
F3 was played but now Knight captures on
B4 we said that once the B4 Pawn is
eliminated
then it's incredibly difficult to defend
Queen to C1 offering a queen trade but
again Queen to A5 threatening very nasty
discoveries here so King to E3 Sid
stepping the discoveries and now Pawn to
D5 you could also just uh trade here
like Knight to D5 check uh and after
King to F2 just go Knight to C3 uh
cutting off the Queen's defense of the
of the bishop and also if the Knight
captures first you play Queen captures
and C5 with check King to F1 and queen
captures and C3 uh you're just up three
pawns you don't care if Queens get
traded off or not if they do it's I mean
even simpler but you are up three pawns
H but Norbeck um he sort of enjoys the
thrill of the hunt doesn't go for the
trade he plays D5 he wants to Checkmate
the white king Knight E to D2 and now
Pawn to H5 param again was down to some
30 seconds on the clock here uh even
though uh there there was an even
stronger move Bishop to beat you just
removing the White Queen from the
defense of the Bishop on C5 but okay H5
was played we have King to F2 trying to
find some sort of safety here h captur
on G4 now Knight to B3 attacking the
queen uh Queen back to C7 uh and now uh
Queen to D2 if you move the knight uh
then you lose control over the H2 Square
Queen H2 check will be a problem so
Queen to D2 was played now comes G
captures on F3 and Bishop captures on C8
F captures on E2 King captures and queen
captures on C8 and he was in in this
position on move 34 that param makulu
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it's just uh a
position where you don't really have a
move that you can play uh although it
seems like okay uh you could maybe play
Bishop captur on B4 but then Queen to G4
with check or queen to A6 with check and
you just
get well there there's nothing you can
nicely connect with the bishop even King
to F1 Rook captures on B4 and the
material is equal if you don't count
pawns if you count pawns black is just
up for pawns but the white King on E1 uh
of course there is um no point in in in
playing this so after Queen captures on
C8 param uh decided that it was time to
throw in the the towel uh maybe he even
lost on time I can check uh I'm not sure
uh but yeah I can check uh let me just
check real quickly yeah Queen C8 no he
had 35 seconds on the clock which means
that he made his last move with 5
Seconds on the clock so he didn't didn't
lose in time he resigned here uh but
yeah pretty hard game and even though it
was winning for him had that Queen to A3
move been played it seems that both of
them missed it but I'm really hoping you
guys did not uh so I hope you guys enjoy
that and yeah these are the these are
the standings after the three rounds
have been played the current leaders ala
fua and Anish giri then with two points
Yan pish dingler and not Abdus satra
with a point and a half GES pran way vit
guati and Max varban with one point
Jordan v Forest after winning finally a
game against women's world champion juun
and on half a point jjun Alexander
donchenko and param makulu and uh who is
the next opponent for notb in round four
it is of course the leader ala Fu J notc
will have the wait he was black in this
game what uh I kind of remember that he
will also have black in that game let me
just check that real quickly I don't
want to trick you guys uh yeah he will
also be black against alza so he gets
double black in a row uh but yeah what
are you going to do I mean if anyone is
winning uh uh games this tournament is
black I mean every round we have like
four black wins uh so you know uh good
good news for Norbeck but yeah ala is is
a tough opponent so uh probably a game
that we will cover as I'm expecting uh
it to be a a wild one uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by by both of them but Paran
missed the queen A3 move and Notre takes
the win I would like to thank Welsh fan
Mark Henley Brenan best content maker
Brian pin and Y yunong for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh uh you know and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day